trump also with his continued delusions  of grandeur claiming that he saved merry  christmas  remember i said we're going to save  christmas merry christmas we saved merry  christmas didn't we the department store  said don't buy if they don't have  merry christmas they were  told it's not good  they want to get rid of christopher  columbus but more importantly merry  christmas but they say merry christmas  again don't they right whole different  thing this is what i call dumb red meat  it's an attempt to be red meat but  instead of being the type of stuff we  used to see like about welfare queens or  whatever the case may be it's just  dumb red meat